If I stare like this, do you
find you more persuasive?
How about like this?
Anthony here for D News.
And we've often been
told that eye contact is
the key to being
powerful or persuasive.
Whole books are devoted to
the power of eye contact
and how it's going to improve
everything from your job
to your romantic
life, except no.
See, some new findings
were just published
in Psychological Science that
say direct eye contact actually
makes people less likely to be
persuaded by you, especially
if they were skeptical about
you or your ideas before.
How'd they figure that out?
Well look me directly in the
eye, and I will tell you.
Two experiments--
experiment one,
using eye tracking
software, researchers
measured the amount of
eye contact subjects
made with the
speaker in a video.
The more they focused
on the speaker's eyes
while they gave their
opinion on an issue,
the less their attitudes
shifted to match.
Experiment two--
people were asked
to either look in a speakers
eyes or at a speaker's mouth
during a conversation.
And people who
looked into the mouth
were more receptive to
the speaker's opinion.
The reason we're told
to use eye contact
is that it exudes
confidence, but this study
seems to show that
it's a confidence that
comes from a place of trying
to assert dominance or use
intimidation.
That's why animals
aren't into eye contact.
It's confrontational.
If someone doesn't
agree with you
and you look them
in the eye, there
might be a whole set of
subconscious psychological
reactions that put
them on the defensive.
Of course, it's situational.
In a closer
relationship, eye contact
is a sign of connectedness.
It's also cultural.
Here in the US and a lot
of European countries,
a certain amount
of eye contact is
required to show that you're
paying attention to someone.
In some Latin American,
Asian, and African cultures,
it can be considered
aggressive or disrespectful.
There's also a school
of thought that says,
even though too much eye
contact seems inappropriate now,
that wasn't always the case.
A study shows that
adults in the US
make eye contact for about
30% to 60% of a conversation,
and that used to be
around 60% to 70%.
So why do they think it changed?
Mobile phones.
See, people check their
phone about 150 times a day
on average.
And we've just gotten used
to there not being eye
contact during a conversation.
So we get uncomfortable
with it faster.
So how much eye contact
is the right amount?
Now, assuming you are in a
country that feel similarly
to the US, a social
consultant pegged it
at seven to 10 seconds
at a time for one
on one conversations and
three to five seconds
at a time in a group setting.
And a study in Applied
Neuropsychology
showed that if you need
information from someone,
more than 10 seconds
of eye contact
will actually affect
their short term memory
and make it harder for
them to answer questions.
My eyes dart around
too much, I think.
And I am definitely bad
about looking at my phone
all the time.
How are your eye contact skills?
Let us know down
in the comments,
and subscribe for more D News.